good day everyone and welcome i'm jack
van horn from the university of virginia
and i am proud to welcome you to this
edition of our 2021 2022 foundations of
biomedical data science seminar series
this lecture series is supported by
uva's integrated translational health
institute of virginia the uva brain
institute the college of arts and
sciences the school of data science and
through a grant from the national
institutes of general medical sciences
our theme for this year is ethical
challenges of artificial intelligence in
biomedicine where we enjoy presentations
on fridays from leading thinkers about
the promise opportunities and hurdles
associated with ai applications in the
biomedical sciences
selected participants in our biomedical
data science innovation lab program will
leverage these presentations as vital
material for a culminating in-person
grant project development workshop to be
held here in historic charlottesville
virginia in june
today i am delighted to welcome our
speaker sean baez from michigan state
university where i learned today that he
has been for 11 years
and he is an associate professor and the
director of the michigan state
university center for bioethics and
social justice he earned his bachelor of
arts in 2005 from st john's college and
m.a from indiana university in
bloomington in 2008
and his phd at indiana university at
bloomington in 2010. he is a philosopher
of health focusing on evidentiary and
ethical complexities of how social
context shapes health he is the author
of the 2018 book philosophy of
population health philosophy for a new
public health era
that he um
was also had a co sorry he is also a
co-editor with quill kukla of the oxford
university book series bioethics for
social justice
in continuing our 2021-2022
biomedical data science seminar series
theme shawn's lecture today is entitled
interdisciplinarity in the health
sciences and the pursuit of health
equity in sean's presentation today he
will remind us that health equity has
been one of the what most widely
endorsed goals of health science
research at the same time
interdisciplinarity has been widely
endorsed as a means of enriching health
science research but
sean will point out that the
relationships between these two
proposals is not always that clear his
presentation will describe how the
interdisciplinarity framework of
population health science offers a
coherent account of how
interdisciplinary can
interdisciplinarity can directly serve
the goals of health equity with humanity
and humility serving as the key
connecting concept as always we are
streaming this lecture live and for
recording via youtube if you are
watching via youtube thank you so much
for joining us today and also our
specially selected 2021 2022 biomedical
data science innovation lab participants
are strongly encouraged to submit any
questions for sean via this chat feature
in their zoom sessions i will synthesize
these questions and i will ask them
during the discussion period uh of our
presentation today the last 10 minutes
or so of the hour and with that sean
welcome and thank you so much for
providing us with your thoughts and your
vision and your experience we've been
really looking forward to your lecture
thank you very much for the opportunity
to be here i um
it's uh it's it's wonderful be invited
it's a it's a it's of course an honor
and um
uh i really appreciate how uh how
amazingly well organized this whole this
whole show is um it's uh it's been a
pleasure working with uh with the folks
behind the scene here um and so um so so
thank you for uh for making this um not
only possible but also easy
um it seems like nothing is easy now
um
so uh yeah the uh i guess the sort of
the the snapshot view of this has
already been given so i think i will
jump right into this on this
relationship between interdisciplinarity
and health equity in the health sciences
so
uh i'm gonna sort of give you two two
sides of a coin
so on the one hand
for an individual patient
their risk for heart disease for cancer
for
innumerable other sort of health
outcomes
is going to be attributable to a bunch
of different factors
often interacting and a lot of those are
going to be genetic or congenital or or
otherwise sort of hard to um hard to
change for the individual you can sort
of deal with the you can deal with the
hand you got dealt to you by
um by life um but it's very hard short
of things like like gene therapy which
are sort of coming onto the horizon to
actually change some of those some of
those things to actually change the hand
that you were given
um and
in that same vein clinical medicine has
made such a some really amazing advances
towards doing things like improving um
i've just as an example here some uh
cancer death rates they sort of been
going up for for for many many many
years and then
in the 1990s they started actually
declining
um which is really amazing it's an
amazing accomplishment in the in the
arena of sort of dealing with those
individual risk factors especially
um
so uh and this is this is historically
sort of right where i did a lot of my
sort of early early work with sort of
like looking at these like what are
these sort of risk factors how do we
think about them that kind of stuff i i
have a doctoral minor in genetics um and
so i was working on sort of like um
how we sort of conceptualize genetic
evidence and medical genetics
so that's on one hand on the other hand
there are massive between population
differences that are pretty obviously
not genetic or congenital or otherwise
sort of um it's just the way that or
an unchangeable or very difficult to
change aspect of the hand you're dealt
so um so as an example this is a i
thought i would sort of use the
university of virginia you know i'm not
sure where people are uh geographically
but you know um
this is a super high resolution look at
local life expectancy patterns using
data from up through 2015
um there's often a wagon with this kind
of stuff and so um this kind of this
kind of granularity of data isn't
available to almost anywhere in the
world the u.s has
is uh is relatively sophisticated with
our data collection on this kind of
thing
and so
these are basically at birth like what's
your life expectancy if you live in this
little micro neighborhood um it's
actually using uh uh census um
designated areas
so
what i did here is i cross referenced
those those years in that map
with the life expectancies of countries
that have that have almost have
identical or nearly identical life
expectancies to give you a sense of
the way in which we can we can be living
geographically next to somebody or to or
next to a population
and in some sense we're also living
worlds apart
um or at least in terms of this the
scale of the differences so so for
instance i grew up on a sort of like on
the edge of a health cliff in um in uh
partially in um in sort of suburban
boston
and if i if i traveled two blocks east
of me then i would uh uh the life
expectancy would go down on just shy of
11 years
and so that's that's actually not a
typical and so you know you have
sections around the university of
virginia where people are living
87.1 years which is higher than the
highest of of life expectancies for any
country
and
you know just a few miles away of people
living um
less than 74 years so this is sort of
this the scale of differences that were
that we're sort of talking about because
i i i do this in a lot of my talks
because i think there's there's a
it's easy to underestimate how big of
the differences i'm talking about here
um
uh it's or to or to also get a sense of
some of the international scope um the
us is a is an outlier among among high
income nations where we have um our life
expectancy chronic disease rates sort of
like almost every health measure we're
sort of we're
we're well behind or very very very far
behind most other wealthy nations and so
uh
our life expectancy peaked in 2014 we've
never made it to 79 years as a country
on average um and for instance spain got
there in the year 2000.
um i something i sort of i can sometimes
press on maybe even a little too hard
when i'm talking to folks who are
working inside inside biomedical
sciences
because i think the um
there is uh it's easy to assume that
that more technology will sort of sort
of bias more health
and often it can in some ways like you
know those those declining uh those
declining cancer mortality rates a lot
of that has to do with the the um
basically the kind of nih
centered work that that y'all are doing
but at the same time you know spain was
able to get better and was able to
achieve our highest level
at the same time as the as the invention
of the of the ipod
um let alone the iphone like way before
that so um
so this is the so i want to sort of uh i
want to point out this this is sort of
like the scope of what we're talking
about here
in terms of between population
differences so
we're talking about equity
there's nothing about this that's okay i
can't imagine an
ethical system under which it is cool
that there is this these enormous
enormous enormous differences between
populations that have really no
justification there is no vacancy of it
it doesn't have to be this way i'll come
back to that
so
um
so one way of sort of cashing out this
difference is um what uh with
epidemiologist and
sort of population health thinker
prevention preventive medicine thinker
jeffrey rose said is the difference
between the causes of cases and the
causes of incidents
um so this is something that um again
i'll sort of i'll deal i'll delve
further into this and talking about um
population health theory um in just a
little bit but
um they're they're just basically two
different types of causes and effects we
can sort of look at in the world
so it's um so one way of sort of talking
about this distinction between the
causes of
causes of cases versus causes of
incidence is take something like u.s
heart disease risks
so
the causes of an individual person
getting heart disease or not
are attributable to a huge number of
different things and a lot of them are
going to be genetic factors or other
congenital factors like um like
developmental the developmental patterns
that you're sort of just born with
and so my family so personally my family
history my genetic my genetic lineage
all that kind of stuff that all comes
into play my likelihood of having a
heart attack or not in the next 10 years
so that so the so the difference between
whether i get a case of heart disease or
if the person next to me does those
differences are going to be to a large
extent um genetic unchangeable that kind
of thing
at the same time there are massive
differences between on between on
average
heart disease um heart disease outcomes
for black americans and for white
americans and also for also for hispanic
americans like me and so
the the thing is though there are these
big differences between populations
between black americans and white
americans for instance there's a massive
amount of research on that and there are
differences between individuals the
thing that people sometimes mistake
is assuming that it's for the same
reasons and so the difference these
differences between me and another
person and our arts another person
standing next to me our differences in
heart disease risk might be might be due
largely or even predominantly to to
genetic factors
but when there's when there's actually
been focused research looking at
are any of the known genetic factors
that cause that that are known to be
they're known to have play a causal role
in heart disease risks or any of those
accounting for those between race
differences
and uh kaufman had all have some really
cool research they did in 2015 this has
been backed up in a million other
studies in a million other ways
um
that no there is no overlap and so we
have between population disparities we
have between individual disparities and
they're just not they're not
attributable to the same stuff so we
have um
so we have this really annoying problem
that we need to sort of ask different
questions about why is this patient
getting sick as opposed to why is this
population getting sick
um and so they are they are both
important questions but they are not the
same question
so
what we're left with in the case of
something like like like racial health
disparities or i sometimes i
i really prefer to use the term racist
health disparities for for the reasons
i'm about to lay out a moment
um
it's almost always going to be that
these outcomes that we're worried about
and so um so so going back to health
equity
that they're attributable to a racist
racial climate structured around race
concepts not because of actual genetic
differences between um racially
identified populations and so if you
want to talk afterwards about like what
is the what is sort of the state of
knowledge about but average differences
between different populations in their
their genetic makeup or whatever the
short version is no races are not
biological concepts this will hold up
according to modern science they were
they were racist 18th or 17th century
concepts that sort of stuck around for a
long time and we we sort of will these
differences into existence
and so you have massive massive effects
like um
that american indian and alaska natives
um native populations with um this is uh
even before the pandemic where things
got weirder um uh
5.5 years on average less than the u.s
average that's a massive difference
and then people will sometimes say like
oh there's that thing but aren't there
also differences between isn't sickle
cell anemia partially racially patterned
or isn't this stuff about lactose
tolerance and different genetic diseases
and there's some interesting data on
asthma rates somehow being attributed
partially to partially related to um to
ancestry like yeah
yes probably some of that is true but um
it's really important to recognize that
those are essentially going to be
rounding errors within a massive massive
massive uh
exception where
you have
huge huge differences and based on
everything we know about any possible
genetic factors that would be
contributing to that it's going to be at
most a rounding error and some that
might not even hold up over time
so
so when i talk about um a society
structured by racism or it's or uh um or
other sort of formulations of white of
that
um the kind of framework i wanna i wanna
sort of propose to people for sort of
thinking about the range of ways that we
sort of think about the um the causal
structure of the problem of racially
inequitable health outcomes
um this one comes from kamara kumara
phyllis jones who is the former
president of the american public health
association
and she divides it into into sort of
three different
um sort of like zones
and so you can have a racial climate a
racist racial climate
that negatively impacts health outcomes
through three different sort of uh three
different modalities so you have
personally mediated which is sort of the
one that people sort of talk about the
most when they talk about racism is sort
of interpersonal relations in one way or
another
and so you can have a doctor treat their
black patients differently in a way that
is negatively impacting them and so
there's all sorts of research on the way
that that happens
it's
horrible and i try to deal with that as
someone who works inside of medical
school
um it can also lead to things where um
uh
there's a is a big new branch of
research right now on on the role of
stress response
and so um
uh
there's what's called the weathering
hypothesis that seems to have held up
pretty well so far which essentially
says that the um these the chronic
stresses of of interpersonal racism or
even just the experience of sort of
having having all eyes on you when you
walk into a store people walking just
watching to see if you're going to be
going expecting you're going to be
shoplifting
um this sort of this this negative sense
of being sort of discriminated against
and sort of being scrutinized negatively
really takes a takes a physical toll on
the body that can be measured and so
it's um
it wears you down um and uh it causes
elevated
stress stress hormones that take that
basically takes wear and tear on your
body and it causes negative health
outcomes so so there's a lot of
different so it can be sort of like just
negative negative treatment
interpersonally and sort of like the
obvious way but it can also be sort of
the uh
the accumulated effects of other people
sort of like having these little
microaggressions and negative negative
impacts on you over time
um there's also institutionalized racism
um which is something that we are sort
of like gradually starting to talk about
more as a country which like
good um so things like differences in in
socioeconomic status i'll i can sort of
address a little bit more of that later
um access to health care there are big
gaps in terms of um average wealth
average access to health care i can sort
of get get into the numbers but it's uh
it's really quite horrifying
and at the same time there's also um
there's also the phenomenon of
internalized racism which is something
that's that um
it makes a lot of people uncomfortable
to talk about um
but it can it can do things like um
basically people from from marginalized
populations like let's all take the
example of mia so i'm a chicano hispanic
mexican-american
um
and so so there so there are people in
my community who are sort of like who
become sort of nihilistic about about
their uh
about their health prospects
and so you sort of learn to to to accept
the the law that you've been given by
life and so it's like oh well well
um people like us we just get diabetes
and there's nothing we can really do
about that um it's uh it's just sort of
like it's a it's a certain fatalism
about it and it ends up with the same
sort of negative impact as if you have
schools
set up to sort of very very subtly tell
to um tell girls as they're growing up
that girls don't do well in math then
they start sort of playing a social role
of not doing as well in math and so it's
the same kind of it's the same kind of
thing where you start internalizing
these negative messages because it's the
world is sort of like telling you these
messages again and again and again and
eventually people start to believe in
that's that's really horrifying
so all three of these simultaneously and
sometimes interacting will lead to
negative health outcomes and so
that's a lot of different
mediums of of negative impact
and at the same time um so it's not just
not just in terms of wealth there's also
there's also what's called the wealth
health gradient
this is the this is the graph i think
about every year when it comes time to
to find out whether i'm going to get a
raise or not
so this is a graph of life expectancy
again life expectancy is a it's it's a
good sort of shorthand for looking at
sort of like overall health outcomes
um based on your percentile of income
and so for
every percentile of income that you go
up so does
generally your
your odds of living another year
um so this is this is a life expectancy
for 40 year olds and so um so i'll i'll
be turning 40 in a matter of months and
i'm sure wondering like where am i going
to end up on this on this graph when i
get there like if i get that raise maybe
i'll be
farther on this end than on this end
and i would like to
see
my daughter grow up and things like that
and so it's um
uh the the the point here is that um
other countries have have greetings like
this too um the us is relatively unique
in having ours is really steep
um this is these are really big
differences between just like a single
percentile of income so the the one
percent and uh
and the very very bottom percent are are
in very vastly different experiences
so
so what's the what's sort of the
theoretical takeaway that some people
have been getting from this
well the idea is that very broadly and
there are different sort of theoretical
wins for looking at this
is this idea that we that that
effectively promoting health trying to
make it better
is going to require action across the
whole of society so if if our if our
racial health disparities are as a
result of socioeconomic status
and also interpersonal relations inside
the clinic and also the the accumulated
stresses of living inside living inside
neighborhoods where you're being
negatively scrutinized
and also it's the the sort of like the
the insidious development of negative
views about one's own body and one's own
behavior if it's all of that kind of
stuff just just in the example of racial
health outcomes then what we need is we
we need action across the entirety of
society to deal with this kind of stuff
and so this sometimes goes under the
under the label of health in all
policies
which is um
which is
a both a descriptive claim and also a
sort of call to action and so it is
saying whether you like it or not
tax policies for instance are health
policies because whether or not you have
an extra thousand dollars a year could
decide whether or not you live to the
next year
um
uh and on the other hand or at the same
time it is also a call to action saying
that we need to have health in all
policies we need to be advancing health
with our policies because if we do not
recognize that our our decisions about
where to put a new highway are going to
impact whether or not people are going
to be breathing in pollution whether
they're going to have access to
to travel to work whether they're going
to be displaced by by the building of
the new highway all of that impacts
health and so we should start dealing
with this
and so this is an idea that's been it's
been advanced by the cdc and the
american public health association and
lots of other people so it's just sort
of out there
um
so surrounding this
or sort of like underneath this is the
the development of this
theory or this um
it's a
it's an interdisciplinary movement it's
a branch of interdisciplinary science
it's a
theoretical framework it's sort of all
these things at the same time and it
goes under the name of population health
or population health science sometimes
population health framework and so the
person i mentioned before jeffrey rose
came up with that distinction between
the causes of between persons
disparities and between population
disparities
he was a hugely influential figure but
the field sort of got off the ground
initially in that with this 1994 volume
by the canadian institute for advanced
research where they very aptly titled
their this this um this edited volume
saying why are some people healthy and
others not and so
the determinants of of of a healthy
population so why are some people's i
think it's sort of the way they mean it
healthy and others are not
and so what it eventually turned into as
described by keys and gaway who sort of
wrote like the sort of like the main
sort of um
call of the textbook on it
is um it's a research program that
confronts the structural forces so
things like structural racism for
instance that place individuals at risk
that creates distributions of health and
disease unequally across socially
defined groups so think like like for
instance racial groups so it's not
committing to the idea that
that um that whiteness for instance is a
biological category it's a socially
defined group but there are differences
there are distributions nonetheless
and focuses on embedding biological
pathways within social interactions that
develop across the life course you know
from from from in utero through through
death and into the next generation
and across generations
so this is sort of like the theoretical
orientation to it and the thing that's
really um that sets it apart or one of
the things that sets it apart
is i would argue would be
there's a rooting in
uh what's uh what has in in one context
at least been called the fallacy of
health inequity fatalism
and the way that rose put it in in this
1992 book that became very influential
is that there is no known biological
reason why every population should not
be as healthy as the best
so like i was saying at the beginning
there sometimes you're just dealt with
dealt a bad hand by genetics
um so there always be healthier
individuals and sicker individuals if
you're born with a heart defect or a
mutation that causes genetic disease i
wrote my dissertation on genetic
diseases
um then you're going to be at
disadvantage and
we can gradually try to make progress on
counteracting those but you were dealt a
tough hand and so we are we are far away
from from a world in which um in which
we can sort of undo all of those kinds
of things that you so we sort of level
that playing field
but the
the thing that's radical here
is this claim that well
every population is going to have a mix
of some people who are dealt with good
and some people were dealt a bad hand
some people were born with uh with
congenital heart defects and some
weren't some were born with genetic
diseases and um and most are not
and so it might always it might be the
case that we'll always have sick
individuals
but it's not it doesn't need to be the
case that there are sick zip codes
sick neighborhoods
sicker countries
cigarette income brackets
it doesn't need to be the case that
that's that that's so that that's going
to happen
and so so thinking back to that gradient
of your your percentile of income you
know the 40th percentile of income
doesn't have to
die sooner than than the 55th percentile
or even the 41st
because each of those populations has it
has people with a varying level of good
luck in some terms
um
and so so the so so so rose is making a
sort of like a biological claim about
the state of empirical evidence and it's
held up over time but what it really is
functioning as sort of like an ethical
provocation is
is okay but if there are these
differences between between
neighborhoods like that map i showed of
surrounding the university of virginia
well that's the result of
political choices
broadly political choices um that that
we don't we didn't have to do them that
way nor do we have to continue doing
them
and so this idea that it's a it's a
fallacy of a sort of fatalism that like
well
that you have to have sicker populations
like no you don't
um uh so i'm borrowing that terminology
from um from the group called public
health deliberation they just have a new
report that came up um earlier this week
actually sort of like giving that
terminology and i like it
so um so with that background set up um
here's what i sort of brought to the
table when i was sort of looking at this
stuff so i wrote a book um as was
mentioned in the beginning called
philosophy population health because
that's really interesting is like what's
going on with this sort of ideology of
population health what are they doing
that's that's different or interesting
from what other people had been doing
before or are doing now
um
and so
i i was sort of looking at it and i was
like well you know i think they i think
this cert this sort of this approach to
to health is
i don't have any better ideas um i think
this is
about right i think we should be
starting from these kinds of
presumptions i think we should start
with this this this rejection of this of
the assumption of that fatalism
i think we should be taking this
approach of thinking about health over
the life course and so i sort of
redefine what what health should mean
across the life course like i made a
bunch of sort of like little tweaks and
elaborations and things like that
um but what but what i end the book with
which i sort of wish in hindsight i
spent more time doing i've written a
little bit about this afterwards is
i make the claim that that really at the
root of all this is humility that if
that's that it is both descriptively the
case so uh so it is the case that's that
that you know that a prac that practices
of being humble
are key for this for this field as a
whole
about this approach to doing population
health that sort of takes into account
all these different disciplinary
approaches to thinking about how to how
to make health better think of all the
different mechanisms of healthier
populations and things like that
and is also
ethically and ethically the case that i
think we really need to keep being
humble in these same kinds of ways
otherwise this whole this whole house of
cards is going to fall apart
so i'll say what i'll say what that
means now and about what about how this
all ties to interdisciplinarity
so
i i argue again at the end of the book
is sort of like the the sort of like the
concluding lessons is that
we need three kinds of humility to
create a cohesive and equitable culture
of health
so
the basic idea is that health is too big
a thing it is too complicated it is too
multifaceted
for any one person for anyone discipline
or any one sector of society something
like government academia that kind of
thing
to fully understand there is no
privileged perspective on health that is
superior to all others i don't think
there's any grounding for any kind of
claim that like one discipline shall
rule them all
and so we need to act humbly toward
other sectors of society that for
instance that academia healthcare
industry agriculture government
all sorts of other sectors need to be
brought in as partners rather than
subordinates if we're going to try to
make make health better
and we need to act humbly towards other
disciplines since it's going to take
many different methods and knowledge
traditions to understand and to advance
health so this is the kind of stuff i'm
talking about
so so take something like intersectoral
humility
um so this is humility about all the
different different sort of sectors of
society that need to sort of come
together this idea of health across
society that it's going to take to to
promote health
um
so one example i've been i've been
writing about recently is um is mass
incarceration
and so in the united states we've tended
to have sort of like very sort of
bracketed and sort of siloed
conversations about how to think about
um things like policing
and so policing incarceration
it's pretty well known by this point
that there are very very large um racist
health display racist outcome
disparities in terms of
incarceration rates between black
americans and white americans treatment
by the police like these are things that
like should not be too
you kind of have to bury your head in
the sand to sort of like say like no no
these things don't exist these aren't
problems
but the problem is that we we sort of
have these conversations in the realm of
of of justice reform of of criminal law
reform and and policing reform
and what has sort of been much much
slower to have to sort of percolate is
having these be also conversations about
health
because and this is uh from a report
from the robert wood johnson foundation
there are massive health impacts from
from mass incarceration and so we have a
system by which we incarcerate enormous
numbers of people
and
finally people and people in population
out there saying like well we really
need to look at this this is this is
like a really a problem and so these
patterns of mass incarceration create
racially biased burdens on communities
where people
get caught in a spiral of discriminatory
police surveillance and so certain
neighborhoods get massive amounts of
police police attention
and harsher treatments
that leads to
for disparate incarceration rates
then a web of these mutually reinforcing
uh harms that happen even after a
person's release from prisons you have
poverty inability to get housing
poor mental and physical health often
the loss of voting rights overall social
powerlessness and you sort of have this
spiral of these things all negatively
negatively mutually reinforcing each
other
and that's really terrible but these are
conversations that we're not really
having in terms of health at all and so
so this is obviously not only a health
problem
but if we're going to actually have any
real discussion about
about how to
how to deal with the negative impacts of
police killing u.s police killing
civilians at massive rates
um higher than than any other any other
peer country or us incarcerating more
people than any other any other peer
country
then we're we're going to be missing
part of a conversation and so we need to
deal with this as a health problem among
other kinds of problems and so we need
to recognize that we need to start
dealing we need to start talking to
to criminal justice reformers if we're
going to to create a healthier united
states for instance
um these graphs are obviously really
messed up like oh my god oh my god
moving on i can talk about more of that
later if you want
um so
so getting to the interdisciplinarity
so
i
i like the idea that this this sort of
endeavor of population health and
population health science or whatever
you want to call it i i sort of work in
this area and i'm sort of ambivalent
about it
uh in terms of what exactly it should be
called population health something um
it's this idea that it has to be
inherently interdisciplinary and so so
for instance i'm uh i'll be co-chairing
the the upcoming conference um this fall
which i encourage you to look at and
look into uh of the interdisciplinary
association for population health
science and so it is the
interdisciplinary association for
population health science this is the
main population health group
and so um
it needs to really really own this this
respect for qualitative data and
quantitative data and ethnographic data
all sorts of different kinds of
knowledge traditions
and it gets because the kinds of
problems we're faced with are really
really complicated
um and so take for instance um this is a
new article that came out like what day
or two ago um
where it was uh this is a headline from
from stat news um like the medical news
site
and saying expert sphere us may default
to annual covet boosters without
sufficient data
and so i look at that as like okay yeah
like i also want there to be a database
decision to be made about like who
should get a booster every year does it
need to be every year what are the what
are the benefits what are the costs
all that kind of stuff like okay like
yeah i'm i'm down with this idea that we
should sort of like we should think
about that
but then thinking but then the the
enormous challenge that we're left with
is
considering like the enormous range of
expertise that we'll need to synthesize
or at least that we should be
synthesizing to come up with an answer
to something like the question of how
how often to recommend covidaxon
boosters and and to whom should we
recommend them
so so among other things you have um you
have t-cell you know immunologist who
felt like really left out a lot of these
conversations because we really need
t-cell data to know about the durability
of immunity and we it's it's not as easy
to collect that data as some other data
and so
we we've sort of been going with the
data we have not the data we want and so
like
we we really need to incorporate that
t-cell data about how how are these
vaccines performing in like over time
and how much will booster help for
instance
and epidemiologists have been have been
having like a big role in this but um
they they too want more data they want
to
they want to be able to synthesize more
of it they sometimes have a hard time
sort of piecing apart the different
variables that that you might might not
know know for instance though there's a
problem with um
when comparing the performance of
different vaccines
we don't know if there are any sort of
systematic sort of self-selection things
where someone like how do we sort of
factor in that someone might choose to
have gotten the johnson johnson vaccine
as opposed to the modern vaccine the
first time around and how we sort of
like incorporate that into thinking
about like how well do these work
meanwhile health communicators have been
super frustrated that we sort of that
there's this habit in the united states
that including during the pandemic we
tend to design guidelines to follow the
clinical data on efficacy but we don't
necessarily plan around the sort of
known problems like confusion over
getting like really shifting guidelines
about these sort of mixed messages about
what vaccines do and wherein and how you
get them and things like that
and even
even going even more interdisciplinary
philosophers like mia we sort of worry
about who gets to decide what counts as
good enough evidence that is not an
obvious
obvious answer
um so the best advice i can muster here
is sort of like a general advice is that
we should try to be humble about each of
us only having one piece of a larger
puzzle that nobody sort of has that has
the the has the blueprint for how to do
the whole thing we each only have that
one piece of the puzzle maybe sometimes
one people one person's big piece is
bigger than another but it is it is
always a mere piece
of of a larger hole
so all of the so this this intersectoral
humility interdisciplinary humility
they're in some sense sort of like
different instantiations of what's of
what philosophers call epistemic
humility which is basically humility
epidemic just means about about
knowledge and evidence and so being
humble about about our our abilities as
knowers
so um so i i borrow my sort of my
particular concept of it from
from anita ho who's a population health
scholar and also a a feminist
bioethicist
and
the way she puts it is epistemic
humility is a disposition as well as a
commitment
it arises out of professional's
knowledge acknowledgement of the
boundary of their expert domain as well
as their fallibility
it means a commitment to make realistic
assessment of what one knows and does
not know and to restrict one's
confidence and claims to knowledge only
in a a
only to one out one actually knows about
his or her specialized domain in
particular it's a recognition that
knowledge creation is an interdependent
and collaborative activity
i'll come back to that in a moment
both um she's working in the case of um
of like no doctor patient kind of stuff
so both the healthcare provider and the
patient are counting on each other and
investigating a full picture of the
patient's experience and determining the
most appropriate management strategies
and so the reason why i like to i want
to sort of press on this especially in
the context of interdisciplinarity
is this idea that it is a recognition
that humility is a recognition that
knowledge creation is an interdependent
and collaborative activity
and so
a lot of us in in school i mean i even
went to i went to a math and science
sort of like special magnet school
and even in that context i i was really
sort of i was sort of raised into this
idea of of science as being
a fundamentally an individual endeavor
that sometimes you work with other
people on
and that's that's sort of the wrong way
of thinking about this kind of stuff i
hope i i know it's sort of a mixed bag
about whether science education has
improved since since when i was when i
was in elementary school or whatever
this idea that it's an interdependent
and collaborative activity that we need
to work together to sort of to do this
kind of stuff and we need to get used to
the idea of depending on others to sort
of work together to get some knowledge
out of at the end of the tunnel
and so
this is actually a bit controversial and
sort of thinking about like how to think
about humility and i think it might be
sort of worth sort of pressing on this a
little bit so so this will get a little
more philosophical just for a moment um
hopefully for uh hopefully it'll sort of
pay off
so
the worry is and it's been it's been
articulated by um by folks like jose
medina who's uh who's another
philosopher he worries that that um
that saying humility is a good thing is
actually kind of dangerous
so this idea that we should all be
epistemically humble he's like well
that's something we should you should
sort of be humble in moderation
because if hum if humility is
attentiveness to one's cognitive
limitations and deficits
then being too caught up in thinking
about your limitations could be
pathological as to be put or detrimental
to your confidence and character
and so we worry about the sort of thing
we're training like scientists or
doctors that's like we don't want we
don't want a doctor just to fold as soon
as a patient argues against the
diagnosis or demands a different
treatment like that would be bad
and so it's really important we sort of
get really clear on what what it means
to be a humble collaborator or a humble
knower
and so
if you're thinking only about the
boundaries of of your knowledge or
expertise
then
um you if we if you only think about
your limitations and not your strengths
that could be a problem
and so and so the thing that i where i
disagree with him is he's thinking that
humility is just about about recognizing
the boundaries of your knowledge and not
thinking about
uh what's basically the only thing about
what's outside the walls of your
knowledge nothing about what's inside
the walls of your knowledge
and so um
so i like i like who's account better
because she says that it's a recognition
of your strengths
as well as your weaknesses
and it's and it's not only thinking
about your own strengths but it's also
it's also humility is also reflecting on
the person i'm working with on this
what are their
abilities what are what are their
limitations and strengths and so we need
to sort of reflect on not only our own
limitations and abilities but also those
and
others and so
one of the one of the ways this can play
out is this is this idea of um i think
humility in some sense is a is a way of
thinking about sort of like sharing the
lane
and so
if we're going to get at big problems we
need to learn to share the lane
and so
so here's an example of just the police
brutality is our way too according to
doctors thinking about racism as a
public health crisis
racism is not only a public health
crisis but it is a health crisis among
other kinds of crises
so so for instance in my book i defend
the notion of calling a social problem
like
a social problem like gun violence or
climate change um i explicitly talked
about both of those um
that those are you know they can be
criminal justice problems they can be
economic problems but there are they can
be spiritual problems but they're also
health problems
um this is really controversial stuff um
i think it's really important context
that that a lot of this stuff about
staying your lane especially when it
comes to when it comes to health and
this is sort of bubbled back up during
during um
um covered 19 and things like um the cdc
saying um you can't evict people from
their from their rental apartments
because
because it's too dangerous to sort of
put people on the street during a
pandemic and then there's like a big
there's a big backlash thing like no no
no that's like overstepping the
boundaries of what counts as a health
issue housing isn't the public health
issue that kind of stuff
unfortunately the supreme court agreed
with that position
um
and so so some of this actually started
started coming out um when the night the
national rifle association um started
tweeting that doctors need to stay in
their way and stay out of gun control
conversations
and then in reply you had a bunch of
doctors tweeting back with the hashtag
this is our lane and then showing
pictures of their gowns after after
turning gunshot wounds
and so um so that that's the kind of
stuff that's that's really at stake here
when we're talking about how do we think
about sharing the way of like do we talk
about and how do we talk about something
like
gun violence or racism or whatever all
these sort of social social equity
issues as also health issues and then
who should be contributing to the health
issues and health research things like
that
so um
also uh it's just because it's it's been
sort of like um
a topic has been sort of like
coming out in conversation recently as
people have been talking about
solidarity um i think it might be worth
sort of just mentioning here that um
that there there is a relationship
between humility and solidarity
especially since solidarity and sort of
how we how we sort of like form
we express solidarity by sort of being
with other peoples like i'm with you in
this fight against cover 19 for instance
so it's so it comes up inside social
justice conversations and equity
conversations and so i i think it's it's
um important to recognize that this too
connects with humility
um
and so so inside the way i i've sort of
uh i've written about this a little bit
that um
there is an ethical component to
solidarity so like for instance there's
uh
um in the in the in the literature on on
on feminist approaches to to bioethics
there's this idea of like relational
solidarity which is this um this idea of
like i want to be with somebody else and
i want to be attentive to the power to
power and social
and social sort of position
relationships involved in that so i want
to support this social movement trying
to fight for things like criminal
justice reform but i also want to be
really attentive to the way that like
i'm sort of plugging into the system and
there there are sort of power dynamics
that that play
and then but there's also an empirical
component to solidarity that i try to
press on instead of in my work sort of
as someone who's like just kind of like
enmeshed in this sort of population
health context and i think it's not
really um
it's not recognized enough
and so the way the the it sometimes
comes out inside population of
literature including the ottawa charter
for health promotion which was a who
statement
um and so empirically is sort of the
claim here health is created and lived
by people within the settings of their
everyday life this is sort of one when
the sort of the tenets of population
health is that that health happens
in everyday life
period
um it happens where they where they
learn work play and love
health is created and this is again
empirical by creating by by caring for
oneself and others by being able to take
decisions and have control over one's
life circumstances and by ensuring that
the society one lives and creates
conditions that allow the attainment of
health by all its members
and so there's this ethical idea of
solidarity that we we need to work
together we need to sort of be with each
other and try to do things like reduce
those between zipcode disparities
and there's also an empirical component
where
whether or not we can sort of form these
solidarity relationships our health
hinges on those that if we are not
taking care of each other then it it all
falls apart
and so we either work together or we're
just not going to get anywhere basically
um and so
the way that some people try to cash
this out um so like the robert johns
robert roy johnson foundation which is
uh the biggest sort of health oriented
um uh
um you know
private funding agency in the united
states like they they do health and they
pay they put a lot of money into it the
national academy of medicine has sort of
uh has echoed this kind of language and
we need a culture of health
and so um
it's it's a very scary idea that we need
to have all these different aspects of
of culture
all sort of like
intersecting towards are all sort of
like working in collaboration to try to
create healthier living conditions for
everyone so we need the biomedical data
research we need
we need criminal justice reform we need
food system changes we need housing
reform all this kind of stuff all at the
same time and that is very daunting and
very scary but each of us can sort of
put can can sort of plug in in a
different place and so i'll sort of i'll
say a couple words about that then i'll
then i'll stop and
have some conversation
so the way that um so um camaro jones
the one who who came up with that um
uh that diagram of the different ways
that racism can can um can play a role
in health um she she also came up with
this sort of uh which he calls the cliff
analogy
and so
there are lots of different stages of
health and health outcomes that we can
sort of look at and
different places where each of us can
play a role in in sort of like the
research world
and think about okay like what's going
on here
how do we understand it so if you think
about the about
the process of a person standing near
the edge of a cliff falling off the
cliff and getting hurt
and so you can look at these issues at
the point of like risk and so like what
is it
how close can you get to the edge before
you fall off how do we know that
someone's getting getting too close to
the edge can we warn them before they
get to get too close to the edge what do
we do about that sort of that pivot
point between they're fine they're fine
they're fine oh it's looking pretty
precarious and then something bad starts
happening
we can work in the in the in the realm
of prediction and so
what's going to happen to this person
after they hit the ground what kind of
care do they need how can we sort of
allocate resources to them
so that we can we can try to help them
especially as effectively and
efficiently as possible
we can contribute to the to the question
of like what's it like to be hurt
what are the experiences of a person
who's really really being their
suffering what is it like to be ill
how can we understand this and
understand this person and give them the
care and attention they deserve and so
that's another way we can sort of
contribute to this
we can obviously work in the area of
care giving and so like once they get
once they get inside the ambulance
how do we treat them best what what do
we do for them once they're in the
ambulance and so there are lots of
different disciplinary disciplinary
interdisciplinary ways of contributing
to how do we sort of give them the care
they need
and they're also questions of of equity
itself and so
we can ask questions about differences
in quality of care why do some people
get into the nice ambulance and other
people get into the ambulance that's not
so good
um we have differences in access to care
and so or even things like some people
have a a metaphorical fence that
protects them from falling off the edge
and other people they're always sort of
living
they're always sort of
there's nothing sort of there's no net
or fence to sort of protect them from
falling off some people also have nets
to sort of catch them on the way down
the u.s is a sort of infamous in the
international sphere for basically not
having much of a social safety net to
speak of we have very limited housing
support and they're within food security
support things like that like you are
largely on your own united states so
things go wrong
and they're also differences in
exposures and opportunities and so some
populations are always living near the
edge that you're always one
one negative thing uh one negative
impact away from sort of like having
everything sort of spiral out of control
and other people have lots of buffer to
protect them they have lots of room to
roam around
and so
in the in the context of
interdisciplinarity
there are lots of different ways each of
us can sort of can can help you can sort
of study this stuff per se you can sort
of like be one of the ones like i'm
going to look at this equity kind of
issues we can also have an equity minded
lens towards looking at things like
caregiving
or what it's like to be ill and so we
each have a role we can play so there's
a lot of work to be done
but the point is that we'll need
humility to make the to make any headway
on the big sort of rebuilding challenges
to make a better world
and so we need to listen to more kinds
of voices than what we're maybe used to
that it's very hard to sometimes have
conversations with people who have very
different uh perspectives whether it's a
disciplinary perspective or just um a
different perspective because of the of
the kind of life they've lived
uh we need to question our convictions
about our knowledge we need to we need
to think about like what our strengths
and limitations and also the strengths
and limitations of others
and most of all we need to be
collaborative in order to rebuild this
kind of world because um if knowledge
really is a collaborative activity and i
really do believe that that science and
all sorts of and and applied science
it's a team sport
we need to start acting that way and not
be so
not be so obsessed with like who gets to
control this kind of thing and who's
going to be the who has the most
important contribution to this project
that kind of stuff we need to act with
some more humility so i'll stop there
and move to a conversation and hear some
very tiny references
john thank you so much that was really
wonderful i mean you really drove home
the fact that health is just not
an isolated thing it's like so
dimensional and there's so many
different aspects to it one of our uh
participants here loved the way that you
differentiated between causes of cases
and causes of incidents oh yeah
yeah jeffrey rose is awesome
so tell us a little bit more about that
why have you adopted that what was your
rationale for kind of like uh stressing
that it sounds like it made a real
impact
yeah it made an impact on me um
so
i guess i can sort of partially explain
this
autobiographically so um
i like a lot of people sort of work in
sort of like philosophy and ethics and
stuff like that of science and
technology
i i was sort of initially drawn to
things like um
genetic testing and advanced genetic
technologies and things like that and i
think those are those are perfectly
interesting and worthy endeavors um
but i felt like the kind of things i was
interested in were essentially
like it sort of dawned on me one day
like i'm sort of like
i i've been spending all my time looking
at the technologies of the one percent
or like the would be technologies of the
one percent and i felt like it wasn't
where the action is is the way i was
starting to think of it
and so i was thinking about okay like
i'm doing things looking at like new
novel technologies and the possibilities
of gene therapy for
for for different health conditions
and even something like sickle cell
anemia which is uh which is uh which is
a higher burden of disease on black
americans than white americans although
it's not only black americans and that's
a misconception
um
and i was i was sort of looking at that
like well
but
the the disparities between the health
of black americans and white americans
or
between hispanic americans and other
populations all these other different
different sort of disparities those
aren't because of genetics and so i felt
sort of like
like i was sort of not following my
interest in some sense because like i
wanted to get at those disparities and
there are these disparities between
individual people and sometimes they're
they're they are sort of partially
tracking the genetic things
but i felt like i was only looking at
sort of like the rounding errors
um and i wasn't sort of going where the
action is and so like why are why what
are the causes of disparities between
populations why are the where why are
there these these six zip codes and
neighborhoods and countries even like
the united states
and so
that that's what sort of drew me in it's
like okay because it's it's gonna be
just different stuff it's gonna be
different kinds of causes and so it's
not that not to say that the sickle cell
anemia research isn't important like it
really is and then it's and that it's
not relevant to to racial health equity
like yeah we should be investing in that
because that is a problem and it's
it's uh it predominantly impacts a a
population that's been it's been
marginalized by u.s society
but that but that that's not going to
that's not going to deal with most of
the problem of
the vast white life expectancy
disparities and heart disease outcome
disparities and cancer outcome
disparities things like that
i
loved how you discussed humility and its
importance for
us to come together as a
multi-disciplinary science to be able to
solve a lot of these problems and just
basically hear each other out and take
into account all of the different voices
which contribute to this
multi-dimensional health
notion that you described
i'm also keenly aware of the hubris
which seems to exist in our business
where indeed
often a very small but very very
loud
minority of people who are not so
humility
not so humble and have that much
humility and in fact it's kind of their
way or the highway and often that's what
happens i'm curious of that contrast and
what that may mean to you what it may
mean in the philosophy of
you know the population health sciences
yeah i um
that that too frustrates me it also
happens within my field of philosophers
are sort of known for being like
exceptionally arrogant as a as a whole
um or on average
it's a
it's a it could be rather infuriating um
but you see
you have your similar kinds of
complaints about like
all sorts of different different sort of
like uh disciplinary groups or whatever
or subsets thereof
um
for me it's been
like it's obviously annoying and rude
when someone does that kind of thing
when someone's when someone is hubristic
or a bully or tries to run the show
it's it's sort of easy to sort of to go
to the sort of the low-hanging fruit
just say like well you shouldn't do that
because it's sort of bad form or it's
not good collaborative it's not a good
collaborative activity to sort of to do
that kind of thing or insist that you
that you be the pi for no particular
reason that kind of stuff
um
and
like yes that is the case that like um
but i i sort of i found it interesting
for myself to sort of to try to lay out
or like a a sort of like a an additional
few wares of sort of like of rationale
and sort of um
lowercase p philosophy about like
not only is it sort of bad form to to be
hubristic like that to be that to be
that that that um
that kind of person
but that it's
it's also fundamentally
fundamentally counterproductive to
anything inside the inside the study of
health that it is impossible to get an
understanding of health without sort of
working together and to recognizing that
there are sort of um an infinite number
of perspectives on this sort of like
this multi-faceted whole of what health
is
and so it's not only that you that
you're sort of being rude but that
you're that what you're doing is
fundamentally in conflict with our
ability to actually accomplish anything
in this area and so
so you not only are you are you sort of
being a jerk you're also being you're
setting us up for failure
there's a
enormous opportunities here for people
who are working in
data science artificial intelligence as
they are thinking about how to construct
intelligent systems which can help guide
health making decisions about how to
spread the wealth of health resources
around what are some things that you
think they should know as they're
thinking about that that touch on
population health uh health equity and
other forms of fairness if you will
i mean just based on the the things i
i'm not an expert particularly in ai and
and
intelligence systems and things like
that but i i know some of the literature
on it and
you you see fairly
sort of like
more sophisticated or more more sort of
technologically sophisticated versions
of older problems that
when the group of people that are
developing or testing a system
have a certain perspective they're not
necessarily going unless they make it a
point to seek out other perspectives
they might sort of build their biases
into the system
and so
what counts as success or what kinds of
inputs do we put into it and so whether
it's
camera systems that aren't able to track
faces that are that that are that are
darker than the people who develop them
like that's that's something that
that's happened there's even been
satires about exactly that problem the
cameras they can't recognize black faces
um
or whether it's um it's a sort of uh
this tendency to think that okay well my
job as a as a data scientist is just
sort of to build the thing or i'm a data
engineer and so i'm going to i'm going
to build the thing and it's it's someone
else's job to deal with the problem of
okay but like who is it going to impact
and how is it going to impact them
and so that sort of hands-off approach
like well i'm just in my silo over here
and i make things and if it's going to
be used by a health insurance company to
to try to find people to to take away
their their coverage
then that's that's their problem or if
it's it's going to be used as a means
for trying to do
more sophisticated policing or something
like that that it's that's not my job or
something like that and so
recognizing the interconnectedness of
what we're doing and
recognizing that they're going to be
they're going to be disparate impacts on
different populations when you create a
new technology
and being
making it a point to try to find out
like okay how is this going to
negatively how is this going to impact
people from different socioeconomic
groups from different from different
racial groups are are there are there
anticipatable sometimes there are
unanticipated ones are there
anticipatable problems that we should be
looking for now
don thank you so much for a wonderful
presentation for this fantastic
discussion we so appreciate it uh this
has been really an education thank you
so much um thank you to everybody who
joined us everyone have a wonderful
weekend and uh for those of our
participants we will see you all next
week thanks again sean we really
appreciate it thank you very much and uh
feel free to contact me i'm easy to find
at the center for bioethics and social
justice michigan state